[Musik]
Corona nachgehakt was wir bisher wissen
das Corona-Virus mutiert das ist nichts
besonderes bei Viren aber wird das
gefährlich für uns wird es höhere Zahlen
bringen Professor Hendrik streges bei
mir müssen wir vor diesen Mutationen aus
Südafrika und Großbritannien im
Augenblick große Sorge haben müssen wir
Angst davor haben ja wie sie es eben
schon gesagt haben ist es nicht
ungewöhnlich dass Coronaviren mutieren
für das neue Coronavirus sind schon über
4.000 Mutationen nachgewiesen worden was
jetzt besonders ist dass ich mehrere
Mutationen zusammengetan haben und eine
neue Variante gebildet haben so wie wir
das nennen man muss sie im Auge behalten
wir können im Moment noch sehr schwer
abschätzen was es eigentlich bedeutet
wir sehen ja zum Beispiel den Anstieg in
England auch in Irland da ist zum Teil
ein wenig Skepsis auch gebracht ob
dieser Anstieg wirklich durch die neue
Mutation zustande gekommen ist in Irland
geht man zum Beispiel eher davon aus
dass das durch die Weihnachtszeit
passiert ist also dass Menschen mehr
zusammengekommen sind in Dänemark gibt
es die neue Variante bereits auch schon
in einer höheren Zahl und da sehen wir
zum Beispiel keinen Anstieg was ist denn
eigentlich eine Mutation eine Mutation
ist ein wenn sich das Virus so verändert
dass es einen bestimmten Selektionsdruck
nicht mehr gehorcht also es sind
verschiedene Veränderungen in der
Genstruktur des Virus was dann aber auch
eine Veränderung auf der Oberfläche zum
Beispiel bedeutet also wenn das
Immunsystem angreift macht es einen
Druck auf das Virus und ist es dann eine
Evolution die passiert eine Evolution in
the making quasi und wir haben dann eine
neue Variante also sind eigentlich wir
daran schuld dass das Virus sich
verändert weil es weitergegeben werden
will ganz
also man muss sich das so vorstellen
dass im jedem Körper von einem
infizierten Menschen eine Armee vom
Immunsystem attackiert und das Virus
aber überleben will und neue Varianten
bildet und hofft dadurch ein bisschen
länger im infizierten Menschen zu
bleiben diese Varianten können
weitergegeben werden und weitergegeben
werden vom einen Menschen zum anderen so
dass neue Varianten entstehen können und
gelten sie als ein sehr pragmatisch
ausgerichteter Virologe der auch
vermeidet zu sehr Angst oder Sorge zu
verbreiten genau das wollen sie ja nicht
aber wenn diese Verbreitung wenn diese
Ansteckung so viel deutliche ausgeprägt
ist bei den Mutanten
bedeutet das nicht auch dass die Zahlen
die wir im Augenblick haben
möglicherweise in die Höhe schnell wir
müssen solche Varianten im Auge behalten
und wir müssen Sie auch ernst nehmen wir
müssen auch sehen wie weit sie sich
verbreiten
wir wissen im Moment nicht ob es eine
stärkere Ansteckung gibt das sind
modellierungsstudien die wir haben es
gibt keine epidemiologischen Studien
also keine was ist der Unterschied das
eine ist was man im Computer macht und
sich anschaut es müsste dazu führen dass
es höhere
Infektionszahlen gibt das andere ist
wirklich in der Bevölkerung zu schauen
ob es unter den gleichen Bedingungen
mehr Infektionen durch die neue Variante
gibt oder nicht
wenn die Zahlen in die Höhe schnellen
sollten
sind das tatsächlich Zahlen auf die wir
vertrauen können weil sie gelten auch
als jemand der sagt mit den Zahlen muss
man vorsichtig sein wir haben ja am
Anfang der Pandemie erlebt das einfach
sehr wenig getestet wurde dadurch waren
die Zahlen auch verfälscht also
wenn die Zahlen jetzt durch eine neue
Variante in die Höhe gehen sollten dann
muss man das zum einen nachweisen eben
über die Sequenzierung zum anderen muss
man natürlich auch die Zahlen im Kontext
sehen wie viel getestet wurde werden wir
jetzt ungleich mehr von heute auf morgen
testen würden dann würde das sich auch
in den Infektionszahlen widerspiegeln im
Grunde was uns fehlt sind
Prävalenz Studien also wo man
repräsentativ schaut wie häufig die
Infektion in der Bevölkerung vorkommt da
wir unser testverhalten über das Jahr
sehr geändert haben wie sie schon sagten
im Frühjahr ist er wenig im Sommer sehr
viel seit Anfang November wieder im
Vergleich weniger und wir haben
antigen-testsie gemacht werden können
wir diese Phasen nicht miteinander
vergleichen besser wäre es gewesen wenn
wir jedes Mal repräsentativ eine
Stichprobe genommen haben um zu
verstehen wie sich das
Infektionsgeschehen in der Bevölkerung
verhält was kann bei einer Mutation denn
eigentlich noch passieren wir haben
jetzt wahrscheinlich ja so sagen sie ja
auch einen ansteckenderen Virus also
einen Mutanten der ansteckender ist was
kann denn da noch passieren kann der
auch gefährlicher werden es kann
natürlich passieren dass so ein Virus
auch mal gefährlicher wird aber im
Grunde haben wir sowas bei Viren noch
nicht beobachtet weil wenn wir jetzt
sagen das Virus denkt was das ja
natürlich nicht macht ist ja noch nicht
mein Lebewesen will auf jeden Fall
überleben es möchte überleben und wie
überlebt es am besten indem sie sich an
den Menschen gewöhn zum Beispiel dass
das Immunsystem das Virus schlechter
erkennt oder aber dass es in einem
Bereich kommt wo das Immunsystem nicht
so gut hinkommt das bedeutet wenn man
das jetzt auf dieses Virus bezieht dass
es nicht so gut in der Lunge ist weil es
da viel Immunsystem geht nah am
Blutsystem ist und gut angreifbar ist
aber da eher auch tödlich ist oder
gefährlich ist sondern eher in die Nase
rutscht das ist für uns dann lästig sein
langer Schnupfen aber ist es nicht mehr
so gefährlich sie haben mal Anfang des
Jahres gesagt wenn dieses Virus so wäre
wie das ebolavirus würden wir das ganz
schnell fokussieren können eingrenzen
können dann wäre es für die Betroffenen
zwar im Zweifel tödlich aber das Virus
wäre sehr schnell mit gestorben
wenn es sich stärker verbreitet geht es
ja im Augenblick offenbar genau den
anderen Weg
also ja also da das kann man sehr schwer
miteinander vergleichen Ebola hat die
Eigenschaft dass die Menschen die
infiziert sind sehr schnell sehr krank
sind und sich eigentlich nicht mehr
bewegen nicht mehr zu den Mitmenschen
gehen und sich eher isolieren diese
Menschen versterben dann häufig sehr
sehr schnell auch also ist ein sehr
tödliches Virus so dass es die
Weiterverbreitung nicht so stark ist wie
bei anderen Viren natürlich kann man das
jetzt nicht miteinander vergleichen aber
das neue Coronavirus hat die Eigenschaft
dass viele Menschen das Virus tragen
können und gar nicht so schwer krank
sind also noch zur Arbeit theoretisch
gehen können oder mit den öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln sich bewegen können und
dadurch auch eher leichter übertragen
werden kann nichts bewegt uns im
Augenblick so stark wie die Hoffnung
dass wir durch eine Impfung die Pandemie
eingegrenzt bekommen möglichst stark und
dann Zweifelsfall auch viele Maßnahmen
wieder zurückfahren können nun kann er
aber eine solche Mutation ja auch dazu
führen dass der Impfstoff gar nicht mehr
so wirkt ist das eine Gefahr
das kann natürlich passieren dass das
Virus eine Variante bildet wo der
Impfstoff nicht mehr so gut angreifen
kann oder auch einige starke
Immunantwort nicht mehr so gut angreifen
können
in dem Sinne kann man erstmal sagen dass
das Immunsystem ja nicht nur an einem
Punkt angreift sondern an vielen
verschiedenen Punkten auch nach einer
Impfung also nicht nur auf einen fährt
setzt sondern auch viele verschiedene
Pferde so dass wenn es eine Mutation
gibt dass das nicht so schlimm ist wenn
es sehr viele Veränderungen gegeben hat
dann kann auch so ein Impfstoff nicht
mehr wirken aber das Gute ist ja dass
wir jetzt wissen wie ein Impfstoff
funktionieren kann und man sehr schnell
auch solche Varianten in den Impfstoff
einbauen kann es wird gesagt von einer
der Firmen die den Impfstoff herstellt
der im Augenblick auch schon auf dem
Markt ist wenn ein
Virus sich jetzt verändert können wir
darauf reagieren wir brauchen einige
Wochen dann können wir das umbauen wie
funktioniert so etwas ja also der der
Impfstoff ist ja eigentlich nur ein
rna-strang das ist ein
rna-strang ist ja
ein Teil von einem Genom des Virus also
wenn man sich das ich habe da mal was
mitgebracht wenn man sich vorstellt das
ist ein Virus dann ist hier die RNA drin
die diese Luftschlange der Impfstoff
nimmt eigentlich nur genau den gleichen
Teil von der
RNA des Virus nimmt nur so ein ganz
kleinen Anteil und hier ist die
Information für das oberflächenmolekül
vom Virus drauf das wird dann in den Arm
gespritzt nicht das ganze Virus sondern
nur dieser kleine Anteil und die Zelle
baut dann dieses
oberflächenmolekül nach das Immunsystem
sagt einmal halt das gehört ja aber
nicht in den Körper das wollen wir hier
nicht sehen und baut eine Immunantwort
dagegen auf das ist dann passiert und
man ist geimpft weil das Immunsystem hat
sich gemerkt diese Struktur will ich
hier nicht noch mal sehen was hätte denn
geschehen können wenn ich das gesamte ge
ja also das wäre das Ganze Virus bei
einer Infektion kriegt man diesen Anteil
und diesen Anteil zusammen bei der
Impfung nur diesen Anteil das hier kann
sehr krank machen in der bei der
Infektion kann auch Langzeitfolgen haben
kann auch tödlich sein dieser Anteil
macht eigentlich manchmal leichte
Nebenwirkungen in sehr sehr seltenen
Fällen kann es mal zu allergischen
Reaktionen kommen aber bisher gibt es
keine Fälle wo es wirklich schwere
Nebenwirkungen gegeben das heißt im
Grunde muss also bei dem Mutanten
ähnliches geschehen wie in dem ersten
Fall es muss nur etwas umgebaut werden
die Firma wenn sich das Virus verändert
hätte könnte die Firma dann also beim
Impfstoff genau diese Veränderung
einbauen und das dann als Impfstoff
geben was wir auch gemacht werden kann
ist zum Beispiel das ganz viele dieser
verschiedenen Varianten gespritzt werden
also nicht nur
DNA-Strang sondern ganz viele
verschiedene die eben schon vorher sieht
was für Varianten zirkulieren können ist
es so dass der Impfschutz umso größer
wird umso sagen wir mal breiter
gefächert die Antwort meines
Immunsystems sein kann weil da
verschiedene Angreifer unterwegs sind
also es gab ja jetzt eine Diskussion
etwa darüber dass man gesagt hat man
könnte ja die zweite Impfung zum
Beispiel mit einem anderen Impfstoff
machen ja also dass das hat ja für ein
bisschen Verwirrung gesorgt dass man
auch Impfstoffe kombinieren kann das ist
aber in der Tat so dass das manchmal
gemacht wird das kann man natürlich
nicht ohne das vorher mal getestet zu
haben also in einer klinischen Studie
aber im Grunde was durch die Kombination
von Impfstoffen gemacht wird ist dass
man erstmal den ein das eine Signal für
die Immunantworten setzt und das der
Körper reagiert und dann dem Körper
quasi eine Variante davon gibt nämlich
durch einen anderen Impfstoff so dass er
lernt dass es auch anders aussehen kann
also ein bisschen anders sein kann und
dann zusätzliche immun Anworten aufbaut
und dadurch der Schutz eigentlich
stärker und meistens auch länger ist
also kommt es eigentlich darauf an dass
das eigene Immunsystem möglichst
intelligent herausgefordert ist auf
diesen Erreger zu reagieren ja und die
solche Struktur also solche Impfstoffe
nennen wir dann so ein Prime Boost erst
wird das Immunsystem geprimed aktiv zu
sein und dann wird es gepustet dass es
durch eine breite Immunantwort und auch
eine lange Immunantwort darauf reagiert
bei all diesen Mutationen die jetzt auch
entstehen sie haben ja schon gesagt das
ist eigentlich der Normalfall dass die
Mutationen entstehen werden wir immer
mit einem Impfstoff darauf reagieren
können
ja vielleicht kann man sogar auch noch
einen Schritt weiter gehen man kann ja
diese verschiedenen Varianten auch in
einer impfstoffdosis kombinieren so dass
man als
geimpfter dann nicht nur eine Variante
kriegt sondern auch vorher gerechnet wie
viele Varianten vielleicht entstehen
könnten das ist natürlich Zukunftsmusik
das wird noch nicht gemacht aber in
anderen Bereichen werden schon
verschiedene Varianten kombiniert und
geimpft der Grippeimpfstoff ist zum
Beispiel ein vierfach Impfstoff da wird
gegen vier Grippeviren gleichzeitig
geimpft Hendrik Schreck ganz herzlichen
Dank und das heißt wir brauchen jetzt
erst einmal keine große Sorge oder gar
Angst zu haben vor den Mutationen die
Impfstoffe werden darauf angepasst und
das war Corona nachgehakt wir bleiben
beim Thema natürlich dran
[Musik]